first
to lana and key and josh and leaf and
rory
what beautiful beautiful amazing words
nothing anyone could ever say
would do better than to show what a
great man and wonderful father your dad
was thank you
thank you
now it's truly an honor for me
to speak about my dear friend and my
mentor
harry reid of searchlight nevada
as he would proudly refer to himself
first let me say to landra the love of
harry's life for 62 years
who he called his rock
the only time i ever saw harry cry
is when he told me landra had had an
awful car accident and had broken so
many bones
he said over and over again as tears
streamed down his tree cheeks
my poor little landra
my poor little landra
landra i know nothing nothing can
replace the hole in your heart right now
but just know that every single person
in this room
and literally thousands more across the
nation
are holding you in their hearts
as you endure this painful loss with
your family
i lost my dad a month ago but he's still
with me
just as i know harry is with all of us
and will always be
five years ago with the unveiling of
harry's official portrait i said
it'll be quite some time
until we see another like harry mason
reed
five years later
that statement remains as true as ever
he was one of a kind
the presence of so many distinguished
guests at this memorial president biden
president obama speaker pelosi elder
ballard of the church
of jesus christ of the latter day of
latter-day saints and so many others so
many of my colleagues who came here both
present
and those who previously served in the
senate
all of us being here is proof of the
wide and deep impact that harry had
on this world
now that being said
no doubt
harry would be extremely annoyed and
embarrassed
that so many of us made a trip to out to
las vegas for him
i know nothing he'd want less than to
sit through a bunch of speeches talking
about how great he was
but i knew harry will and even though he
wouldn't want it i know a part of him
would enjoy it
he'd sort of be like see sid caesar
after he got some applause no please no
more applause
i got to know harry when i came to the
senate in 1999
here was this man
a soft-spoken mormon from searchlight
a town that was miles away from nowhere
at least in my mind
and here i was a brash jewish kid out of
brooklyn
a
borough that's nearly as populous as the
state of nevada
we're a match made in heaven
i quickly learned that just beneath
harry's soft-spoken nature
was a truly honest and original
character there are so many stories
let me tell you one
back in 2012 during the democratic
national convention in charlotte
harry called me all excitedly and
summoned me to his hotel room late at
night
i knocked on the door and harry let me
in
i'm not sure if landry remembers but she
was there
i thought we were going to discuss some
important issue about the next day's
convention
but before i could gather my thoughts
harry pulled me aside into the small
little bathroom
we were virtually on top of each other
and he lowered his voice
chuck
i want you to take care of something
important he said
before pulling out a wad of cash out of
his wallet and peeling off four 100
bills
you know he said you've been working
hard and do doing a lot of the right
things to be democratic leader but you
need to dress better please buy some
better shoes
now at first i thought harry pulled me
into this little bathroom because he
didn't want landry to see him wasting
400 dollars on the senate's worst
dressed member
but when i asked harry about it later he
said to me he didn't want to embarrass
me in front of landra
that was harry to a t
it was no secret that harry didn't care
for the decorum of public office but he
did know how to dress his part
he cut his hair regularly he shined his
shoes he wore nice suits from clothiers
like hickey friedman that i couldn't
afford
but a few years later i got the better
of harry when i showed up to the senate
wearing a hickey freeman suit of my own
harry was surprised he said chuck
i thought you said you could never
afford a hickey freeman suit
i told them i can so i visited the
warehouse in rochester
and bought one at a wholesale price
harry stopped slipping me money for
clothes after that
now to be clear i don't just travel
around the state looking for good deals
on clothing
for example as many of you know every
year i attend and speak at dozens of
college graduation ceremonies around new
york every may and june
harry of course knew
about this tradition and he thought it
was hilarious
in fact he liked it so much that one day
he gathered all hundred of his staffers
into his office and asked me to deliver
the entire fifteen-minute speech to all
of them
but after i became democratic leader he
started to worry about my habit every
graduation season he'd call up my wife
iris who's here today
and plead with her
you to stop him from going to every
graduation and every event he's got to
garner his strength and his health
that's just who harry was if you were
lucky enough lucky enough
that he cared about you
he called you his friend
and he cared about you with
every fiber of his being
sometimes you could even say cared a
little too much
you know landra wasn't the only woman
i've seen harry cat kiss passionately on
the lips
it was back in 2006
harry and i were watching the election
returns together
they announced our friend claire
mccaskill was the winner of the senate
race in missouri and we would take back
the senate and i kid you not
harry went up to the tv screen
and smacked claire on his lips on hers
his lips remained attached to the tv
screen for a full 10 seconds
he kissed claire's image so passionately
i had to get up and wipe the copious
spittle off the tv screen
that's how much we all loved harry
so harry in short was one of the most
incredible individuals i've ever met
the sort of person you come across only
a handful of times in your entire life
he was tough as nails a fighter to his
core
but also one of the most compassionate
individuals you could ever imagine
he never forgot where he came from
he always stuck up for the underdog and
the little guy
i believe harry drew a lot of that
compassion from his faith
he grew up of course as everyone knows
in a town with more than a dozen
brothels and no church
but as many here know after harry moved
to henderson and met landra
they both converted to the church of
jesus christ of latter-day saints
harry kept the book of mormon in his
office
and i'd like to read a verse from second
nephi
chapter nine
that gives me great comfort
after the loss
of my dear dear friend and mentor
oh how great the plan of our god
for on the other hand the paradise of
god
must deliver up
the spirits
of the righteous
and the grave deliver up the body of the
righteous
and the spirit and the body is restored
to itself again
and all men become incorruptable and
immortal
and they are living souls
they are living souls
when you lose someone special
they're never truly gone
they always
stay with you
for those of us in the senate democratic
caucus i think that was especially true
this past week
as we observe the anniversary of the
violent insurrection
against our u s capital one of the
darkest moments for our democracy and
living memory
today saw so many acts of selflessness
and heroism
by our by our u.s capitol police
who once counted among their esteemed
ranks
one harry mason reed
who served as an officer while studying
at george washington school of law
in so many ways so many ways harry was a
guardian and steward of the senate
literally and figuratively
he took great care of the senate
as an institution
but he also knew that the senate had to
adapt
to changing times
as we confront the challenges of the
coming weeks and months ahead i take
comfort knowing that harry is with us
in spirit walking alongside us he's
right there
as we continue the work he dedicated
himself to
for so many so many years
may god rest his immortal soul
may his memory
be a blessing
to all of us